Well, another extremely sort of, you know,
liberation-inducing woman comes to mind is Madonna.
Is it true that "Express Yourself" was written about you?
It would be weird for me to say that
if it weren't true that she said it to me.
That's crazy!
I mean, she said it to everyone.
I don't know, she.
It's possible.
You were really good friends with her.
Okay, we were super tight at that moment.
She was the one who was just broken up with Sean,
I had just broken up with Matthew, I (imitates crying)
and she threw a party for me, and she was, yeah.
I mean, that is, that's good times.
That's my Polaroid.
That's good times.
That's the stripper party that she threw for me
at Canal Bar, where she had the the waiter start to strip
to "Time of Your Life."
Oh my God.
And it knocked me down,
and then goes really, so why yield, okay.
So here she was, like saying to me, like,
you know, being that girlfriend that,
everyone needs a girlfriend who can tell you
if you did the right thing, or it's gonna be okay,
you'll meet someone else, or whatever.
And then I was living in Laurel Canyon,
'cause I remember where I was, and so I'm in the log cabin,
Carrie Fisher's log cabin in Laurel Canyon.
And she said, "Hey, I just did a song, come into my,"
she was in, she had a Mercedes,
like what are those old two-door Mercedes?
Oh, like an SL?
Yeah, the old ones?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So she goes, I said, "Well, let's listen in here."
She goes, "No, my sound system's better."
So we get in the car, she closes the door,
and she plays it for me.
And she said, "I wrote this, you inspired me."
So she's never said it publicly.
And I actually wrote her recently and I said,
"I wrote about you in my book. Is this true?"
And now she was just like, "Send it to me."
Okay, Tom Cruise.
Yes.
You were doing a screen test with him,
and was there something about?
For "Cocktail."
For "Cocktail." How did that go?
What was Tom Cruise like?
Well, I was friends with Tom Cruise.
I met him at a No Nukes Rally.
I was kind, I felt like his older sister.
You know what I mean?
Like he was asking me for relationship advice
and stuff like that.
So we go to the screen test,
and I'm like, okay, he's my old friend.
So then we have to do the bed scene, some love scene,
and it's a chemistry read.
They're trying to see how hot you are together
and feel that uh-la-uh.
And I just couldn't stop laughing the whole time.
And the more I laughed, the more mad he got,
until finally the director goes,
"Okay, I think we're done here."
And I was like, "I'm sorry."
(audience laughs)
Okay, let's try again.
(imitates restraining laughter)
When you get those giggles, you get the giggles.
But what's so cute is I hear a story like that,
and I think about the moment that Patrick Swayze
is going down your arm
See? Again.
and that giggle is something that we all love so much.
It's a part of cinema history.
It's the cutest, most endearing, sweet moment of that movie.
(audience applauds)
Thank God for your giggle.
You know, I'm ticklish.
I'm just, I'm really glad that you decided to,
'cause I am a work in progress.
I want to figure things out.
I've been struggling every day to grow up.
It turns out growing up is not overrated, I really like it.
It's amazing.
It's so good.
It gets better and better, exponentially,
that's the crazy part.
Because you talk about my early life
and all my adventures and stuff, I was crazy and unhappy.
It was so crazy and so unhappy,
and it looks like very exciting and fun, which it was.
But what happens is I was like spinning out,
and it wasn't 'til it all just fell apart that I started
to understand who I was and what made me happy.
That book is my truth. It's my story.
And I welcome anyone to write their own story.
And I welcome anyone in the book to write their story
because that's what we have. Right?
I'm so glad you share it and encourage us all.
(audience applauds)
And I love that you talk about the second half
of a woman's life can also be the best part.
Also? It is.
I agree.
Well, thank you so much for coming here
and talking about this amazing book.
Your new memoir, "Out of the Corner" is out now.
And thank you for all these fun, yummy details.
And guess what? Everyone in the audience is getting a book.
(audience cheers and applauds)
And I thank your publishers and our producers
for being able to do that.
"Out of the Corner."
I'll be in a corner with you any day!
I'll take myself there.
(upbeat music)